well the nhl will wrap up its season
awards tonight with a virtual show from
its headquarters
in new jersey sports director chris
matthews joining us now
to tell us that there is a night up for
one of the final five awards right
that's right there's still one guy out
there all the big awards handed out
tonight golden knights fans will be
paying close attention because
marc-andre fleury is up for the vesna
trophy giving her the best goalie for
the season
all these awards were voted on prior to
the postseason now under normal
circumstances
this awards show would be held right
here in las vegas it's been here a
number of times in the past
we all remember when the award show was
first held the palms back in 2009
then the win held the show the mgm got
involved boy it's a terrific night
celebrating the superstars of the sport
of hockey
tonight they will hand out that vesnan
trophy they'll probably end up going to
tampa bay's goalie andre vezilevsky but
flower and philip grubauer are also up
for that award
it's amazing goalies and i have a lot of
respect for them and
you know even though i've been playing
for a long time i i still love
uh watching goalies and uh in the age on
what they do and how they move and
uh how they do things you know and those
two are obviously
very nice to watch and i think there's
so many good goalies around the league
and
you know there could have been three
more guys out there but
in my in my head i think veslavsky is
probably the best school in league where
it is all in the world right
all right the other awards handed out
tonight the lindsay trophy the league's
most valuable player than the heart
trophy to the player who
meant the most to his team the calder
trophy will be awarded to the rookie of
the year
the norris will be given out to the best
defenseman this season
then after tonight all the attention now
focuses on the 2021-22 season
and lo and behold the golden knights are
favored along with colorado and tampa
bay once again
the usual suspects chris